توتر كبير وحاله من الغليان على الشريط
الحدودي الفاصل بين اوكرانيا وبلاروسيا
الخط الفاصل بين الدولتين لم يعد اسلاكا
شائكه بل قنبله موقوتا على شفل انفجار
تعزيزات لحرس الحدود البلارسي يقابلها دعم
عسكري اوكراني مدججا في بعض الاحيان
بالمعدات الثقيله كليه
مختلفه تحدث خلال الفتره الاخيره على سبيل
المثال دخل ذات مره في فصل الصيف وعنصر
اوكراني نحو الاراضي البلاسيه وكان يمسك
قنبله يدويه ويهدد بتفجيرها واسعف حينها
زملائه الامر وصحبه
في ظل ظروف الحاليه تقوم مين سكربيبه
موسكو بيراصد التغييرات المتقلبه حاله
استنفارا للتدخل السريع لدى اي طارئ محتمل
خاصه ان الاخيره تقوم بمراقبه الحدود بشكل
كامل بين البلدين عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث من الحدود البيلاروسيه
الاوكرانيه